malgré les efforts du groupe de
chasseurs ce n'est pas une bonne journée
pour la chasse aux phoques
seulement une toute petite surface doux
libre qui permet de percevoir quelques
bêtes
mais les tirent
on engage des chasseurs locaux puis on
prend des jeunes qui ont pas la chance
souvent de sortir puis d'aller découvrir
la chasse puis on prend ses jeunes là
pour l'été ensemble on paye la journée
on sort sur une journée complète à aller
chercher des phoques aller chercher du
caribou à aller chercher de la perdrix à
la chasse à l'outarde en collaboration
avec l'école secondaire du village
l'organisme sérivique finance des
sorties comme celle-ci pour aider à la
transmission des traditions de chasse et
de survie c'est important qu'on garde
notre identité notre culture notre
fier pour être capable de passer les
défis qu'on a dans la vie économiquement
ou bien socialement
de la chasse et de survie dans la
toundra les jeunes sont stimulés les
jeunes hommes sont fiers de sortir sont
fiers de montrer leur skill que les
jeunes filles commencent aussi à vouloir
aussi je veux aller chasser
l'organisme a bu non lucratif sérivique
finance plusieurs d'autres activités
pour aider les jeunes et les moins
jeunes à se sortir de la sécurité
alimentaire
en 200 et 300 services à une journée
avec une fois par semaine on va cuisiner
une réalité qui n'est pas nouvelle ou
numérique
aujourd'hui les cuisines de la résidence
étudiante avait tellement mis sur pied
un système d'entraide pour sa communauté
[Musique]
un enseignant d'une petite août à
l'école secondaire a aussi fait sa part
pour la communauté grâce à des
subventions
maintenant
puis pouvoir la distribuer à quiber nos
besoins donc on était à William tu
passes assez rivet quand tu veux tu vas
t'installer des tables
participants qui dit cette nourriture là
sauver ma vie à la maison j'ai 6 petits
enfants puissent à nourrir donc ce que
vous lui a fait fin grosse différence
hydroponique on produit une herbe qui
s'appelle le public qui est une herbe
qui est locale oui c'est un peu plus de
travail mais ça pousse très bien en
hydroponique
et l'organisme offre également des
ateliers de cuisine pour les jeunes
c'est de montrer aux jeunes que les
choses se passent compliquer que ça à
faire les cuisines de base puis je peux
survenir à tes besoins
une génération qui navigue entre
tradition et modernité
à nous de jouer le centre de formation
professionnelle accueille des adultes du
numérique pour diverses formations
professionnelles dont le cours de
cuisine offert par Sylvain paradis
le diplôme leur permettre avait comme
cuisinier dans les mines du Nord ils
vont pouvoir travailler dans les
hôpitaux avec les diplômes ils peuvent
travailler aussi à la Résidence scolaire
ici où il y a des cuisiniers pour les
élèves
après une chasse au phoques infructueuse
notre groupe s'est déplacé sur une île
après avoir repéré le passage de caribou
comme culture
[Musique]
pourquoi c'est important d'apprendre
tout ça
une partie de cette venaison sera
utilisée par Hans et son équipe pour
cuisiner un repas hebdomadaire puis
chacun des chasseurs prendra sa part le
reste pourrait être servi lors d'un
repas communautaire ou encore déposer
dans ce qu'on appelle le congélateur
communautaire les chasseurs de
communauté va aller chasser le cariboule
les prosters ils vont amener tout ça
dans le frozen food house
compactage le sagesse du passé parce que
nos ancêtres ont survécu dans des
périodes ou des situations extrêmes moi
je mange beaucoup des éléments que je
cherche moi-même je partage avec la
famille puis
une belle vie
dans 10 ans 15 ans est-ce qu'il va avoir
assez de gens qui vont encore chasser
pour subvenir aux besoins de leur
famille et de la population vous êtes
convaincus de ça je suis convaincu parce
que dans le passé il y avait des génies
qui posaient le même question il y a
déjà 40 ans puis ça continue